hey everyone it's Mike from Immortals
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we'll be talking about one of my
favorite trade setups
um but before I jump in you know if
you've been enjoying these videos be
sure to subscribe to the channel and
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new uploads and if you find
today's video helpful be sure to hit the
like button for me and leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway you know I
love hearing your feedback I often make
videos based off of your comments right
suggestions that people want to learn
more about order flow so your sport
really does go a long way in helping me
create more content just like this so
let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic all right uh one of my
favorite favorite favorite
trade setups is the exhaustion print and
this was something that I've been using
in the order flow for you know a long
time I can remember it's one of my
original sort of order flow trade setups
that I always look for in the market and
you know as you know generally uh at
each price level you know Market does a
good job of distribute in volume right
there's a lot of volume traded on the
bid a lot of volume traded on the offer
and what an exhaustion print to me is
it's a sign that the last buyer has
bought in an up move or the last seller
has sold in a down move and today in the
um bonds you know it hit on both ends of
the range it hit on a high and it hit on
the low and
you know when I first developed the
order flows Trader software just a
little bit of a backstory for you guys
um I didn't plan on getting into the
software business right I was trading
order flaws using a regular footprint
chart but
you know there were certain things in
the order flow that I'd always look at
you know and you know there's the ratios
the overflows ratios was something that
I devised years ago which have been
copied by a lot of people the exhaustion
print right which basically is just a
simple thing to identify it's simply
looking at the volume and seeing how
much volume traded if it was under a
certain amount to me that was a sign
that the last
person that was buying an up move had
bought or the last seller selling in a
dawn move had sold and you know years
ago back in the 90s Tom DeMark I
remember sitting in a room with him and
you know he was talking about all the
different forms of analysis right this
is around the time his book
um
on you know his first book came out I
forgot the name of it technical
something about technical analysis but
uh
sorry Tom and
he said something that always resonated
with me and again this was back in the
the mid 90s he says a move is over when
the last buyer has bought the new
science of technical analysis that's the
name of this book I believe when the
last buyer has bought the move higher
will end or when the last seller has
sold
the move down will end because there's
no more selling pressure right just that
there'd be no more buying pressure on a
move up and looking at a footprint chart
this is like one of the things I
identified very early as as a Trader
yeah I could see that because I'm seeing
the volume that's trading on the bid the
volume trading on the offer right I
could see at the high of the day okay
let me just uh remove these lines here
because people say well I can't see
because there's this green line well
that's how I know it's the high of the
day and the low of the day so I'll just
remove this thing here that says Uh
current day open high low close
okay let's let's remove that hit that
back and get the chart back here okay so
I can see up here four Lots traded just
as down here two lots traded okay so I
know
that's telling me that
on the low of the day
there was only two lots traded and the
market reversed it started trading
higher just at the high of the day
traded four
it's all that can trade there's no more
buying interest Market starts reversing
and sells off and why is that important
okay for a number of reasons one
obviously there's there's no more buying
pressure right aggressive buying or
aggressive selling to the downside but
you know being an electronic Trader at
training firms Banks Etc I know what
it's like I I you know people always
talk about Market manipulation right
when you're at the high of the day you
always want to trigger you know I just
want to buy that one lot to see if you
know there could be any stops up here at
this high right maybe it could trigger
off you know a stop run just says at the
low maybe trigger off a stop run so I
know that there was no stops at this
level or at this level now that doesn't
mean that you know maybe a tick or two
higher there could have been a bunch of
stops we don't know but it didn't get up
there right you often see
um you know that that's a game that the
locals would always like to play you
know buy one at the market at the new
high you know buy it at the offer to see
because once it prints right if people
have stops there it's going to trigger
all the stops and then you're going to
get another
um you know three four ticks move to the
upside okay just as if you're doing it
at the low of the day you're always
trying to look for it because again this
was a low here at 24 that you had just
made a little bit earlier at 6 40 this
morning now it's coming back back at 7
30. and there was some decent volume
here there was a thousand traded on the
bid here 567.
so it gets through there and it can only
trade two that's not a good sign Okay so
obviously there's no more selling
interest there now if you
are looking at a footprint chart right
that's very easy to see right because
you can see two too if you're looking at
a bar chart okay I don't know if I got a
bar chart here right this is
um well Z minis but same thing you can't
tell oh two lots traded down here or
locks traded up here you can't right you
can't see that if I was let me just put
this on a bond chart here so that the
bond I was looking at a four range chart
again you're not going to see that what
the volume was that traded down here
you're just not just as up here you
can't tell that four contracts traded up
here it's impossible right and I see
people posting stuff yeah I follow the
order flow and they put up a bar chart
like that what are you following you're
following price you're not following
order flow
okay but if you're looking at a
chart a footprint chart yeah you can see
that and one of the early tools original
tools that we had programmed into the
order flows Trader was the what we call
back then small prints we've since
renamed it to exhaustion prints because
it's really a sign that the market is
getting exhausted okay and you can see
it right in here exhaustion prints now
these are two ways you could show it on
your chart right
the original way was simply just uh
highlighting that box right so I can see
there's exhaustion print and you'll
notice on moves up you tend to see
exhaustion prints coming in at the
bottom of the green candles on a move up
just as on a move down you tend to see
them on the top offer side of the move
down but one of the uh
enhancements that we made several years
ago was the ability to not just draw out
you know highlight that box or Draw out
a little Zone and you could draw it out
if you want
um you know however many boxes you want
you know just maybe you just want to
have a level drawn here so you know you
know an area that trade would be
invalidated by okay
that's if I were to draw it out five
levels but
I like to draw out these any sort of
interesting thing in the order flow
um I like to draw it out what we call
until tested
okay basically what that does is it just
draws out that zone
right until it's tested
and this is something that again has
been part of my trading for a long time
using a footprint chart and oftentimes
you know you see them you know intraday
during
the moves up or moves down or pulls back
pullbacks but today was was special in
my opinion on the bonds on on the four
range chart they happen both at the high
and the low people say well it's because
you're manipulating your chart okay well
if you look at say a five minute chart
still got it right here's your two down
here
's your four up here right you still got
your exhaustion prints and
you know other markets same thing right
ultrabond at the high of the day you had
a three out of three a two exhaustion
prints or this double top coming in up
here I have the exhaustion prints turned
off
but if I were to turn them on you can
see where these exhaustion prints
came in
obviously up here at the high of the day
right here start coming off exhaustion
print but look at this on the move up
two five five two
right on the move up
a market like e-minis it's really quick
he minis is a market that
distributes the volume
fairly well right because at most levels
yeah decent I mean it's one of the more
most liquid markets in the world
okay so you don't get a lot of
exhaustion prints on the highs or the
lows but you do get them a bit in moves
and the way I use them
um in the e-minis let me just turn them
on here
uh exhaustion print I'll just keep it
until tested
okay
let's give it a second for this chart to
come back here
is you know if you're in a trade and you
start seeing exhaustion prints right
going in that direction so if you're
along here from earlier right today this
is around cash opens here and if you're
along and you're seeing the exhaustion
prints
on the bottom of the green candles
that's what you like to see just as if
you're getting short
right and then you see an exhaustion
print you know one two three four in a
row for exhaustion person I'm not saying
you know four in a row is great or
anything but if you're in a trade and
you're starting to see exhaustion prints
at the top of your bars
um the market is going in your direction
that's a good sign okay and a nice move
down today right we had a nice that
sharp sell-off around uh 9 15 today 9 15
and 9 30.
UM in the equities so again it doesn't
matter what Market you're using right
this is
10 years so this is a what is this
uh four range chart this is today
um again once you're familiar with them
you start to you can see them easily I
mean you're just looking at a market
like this right you can see seven
five two but really what you want to see
them coming in for trade opportunity
purposes is at
after moves right at swing lows or swing
highs not just anywhere
okay if it pokes up puts in a little bit
of a swing High here yeah that's going
to be more effective in my opinion than
this one here as the moves already
happening I like it that's coming in on
a move but for trading purposes I'd like
them come in sort of at swing highs
swing lows obviously highs of days and
lows of days now again the the thing
with them with these exhaustion prints
is you're not limited
to well I use a value of nine in most
markets right on markets like
10 years to trade a ton of volume you
know each bar is you know in the tens of
thousands of contracts or sixteen
thousand twenty five thousand thirty two
thousand you know maybe I could
make it a little bit bigger right you
can make it 25 or even 50 if you want
but uh let's make this 25
and again it's it's not a number that's
necessarily set in stone right so you
can see here's 1948 on the way move up
get up here now here's 27.
people so it's not exhaustion print well
again as a Trader
this is a decision you have to make if
you're using it you know when you're
using the software right you have to set
in a value you have to set in a number
or threshold right if I'm using 25 it's
two contracts more
does that mean it's not an exhaustion
print well no you can still take it
because look at the volume it's 22
300 contracts trade on this bar and it
only traded 27 at the high every other
price level
the lowest there's 200 here but 500 700
2 000
5758 1900 5000 and just 27.
so maybe you're willing to take that
shot off of this exhaustion print if
you're going to say well you know it's a
27 it doesn't meet my threshold of 25. I
think you're just uh you're splitting
errors there
okay you see down here right a little
pullback 13.
here at the low of the day exactly 25
this was uh what day was this yesterday
29th right
right at the low of the day you've got
exhaustion print 25 contracts this bar
traded 12 000 contracts 25 trade here
and you got a nice move up okay so you
know that's the whole concept of
exhaustion prince it's nothing fancy
right it doesn't have to be something so
complicated oh I gotta use this I gotta
rip out a calculator or draw squiggly
lines no you're just looking at the
actual volume that's being traded it's
simple it's not complicated right you
know as Traders you want to keep things
as simple as possible
because that's going to give you the
good trade opportunities right things
that just make sense and this was
something to me that just made total
sense to me ever since I started using a
footprint chart I you know I took
because I didn't start using a footprint
chart until you know I don't know what
year
2010 or something around there
but
I was able to take all the knowledge
that I had gained in understanding
because I've been training electronic
trading since electronic trading
basically started back in the early 90s
so I've been looking at a dome
right because that's how you know we
trade on Globex right you'd have the
price level then you can see the Dome
and Marcus didn't move as fast as they
do now I mean you know there's something
in the bid below the market it's
probably because it was a GTC or
something but I took all that knowledge
I had gained over those years of sitting
on a trading desk training
electronically
um on the Globex system you know the
project day and IMAX and eventually it
just became Reuters too and the
regulator is just called Globex but um
you know that's what goes into my
software right that's why we have all
these tools
in the order flows Trader right these
are all tools that
I've developed
okay Concepts that I've developed based
off of my years and years of experience
all right everyone hope you guys enjoyed
that video be sure to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't then I'll catch
you guys on the next video bye-bye